senadora rosa galvis días pasados el
gobierno federal presentó una iniciativa
que tiende a reflotar su objetivo de
llegar a emisión contaminante cero de
aquí al año 2050 cuál es su opinión
sobre este proyecto
y mire estoy muy contenta de que como
país estamos dando este primer paso para
alcanzar emisiones netas de gases de
efecto de invernadero a cero y que
nuestro acuerdo con el nuestro
compromiso con el acuerdo de parís para
enfrentar finalmente la crisis climática
es se de un cuadro que nos va a empujar
a alcanzarlo algunas de las voces
críticas respecto de esta iniciativa
sostienen que debería comenzarse antes a
esa la evaluación de la marcha de este
proyecto hay una primera etapa que está
prevista a completarse en el año 2030
creo este que esta es una fecha
razonable creo que debería acelerarse el
proceso cree que debemos esperar hasta
ese momento
efectivamente algunas personas han
declarado de que porque tenemos que
esperar verdad
porque no ponemos objetivos más cerca yo
pienso que es importante de recordar que
en canadá tenemos diferentes provincias
y territorios que cada uno de ellos
tiene diferentes situaciones y por lo
cual el gobierno puede dar el cuadro
pero es a cada provincia de
verdaderamente ver cuál es la manera que
les conviene más pero por otro lado lo
que yo le puedo decir es de qué
[Música]
entre ahora y el primer momento en que
se tenga que llegar a un objetivo pues
hay muchas cosas que podemos ir haciendo
verdad justamente hemos propuesto
nosotros en mi oficina del senado y un
libro de discusión sobre cómo construir
un futuro mejor una recuperación limpia
y justa
después de la pandemia del cob y 19
verdad y cada provincia si se debe por
ejemplo el que ve que también acaba de
lanzar su libro verde y también tiene
sus objetivos entonces yo pienso que no
es que las provincias deben quedarse ahí
esperando que el federal
ponga más detalles si no verdaderamente
arrancar ya porque la cob y 19 es una
oportunidad de poder construir mejor a
un futuro más y una prosperidad más
durable usted nombró al acuerdo de parís
y desde que éste fue firmado muchos han
dicho que se ha avanzado muy poco no
solamente en canadá en diversos países
en el planeta y también se dijo en su
momento que ese acuerdo de establecer
metas demasiado exigentes o poco
realistas en todo caso que es distinto
en esta iniciativa que la hace realista
que hace que sea posible pensar en que
se pueda alcanzar en el año 2050 la
emisión cero de gases contaminantes
la pregunta es muy pertinente es verdad
que según nuestros nuestros datos
nuestras informaciones el canadá no ha
alcanzado ninguno de los objetivos
previos ni aquel del protocolo de kioto
ni el de río de janeiro ni el de
copenhaguen y si seguimos en esta en
esta situación pues tampoco lo vamos a
poder alcanzar el de parís lo que yo
pienso que es importante de decir en
este momento es de que esta situación
del cambio climático la conocemos casi
allá más de 30 años y que más de 20 años
utilizamos la palabra transición verdad
pero transición en la definición es de
que una transición generalmente es corta
se sabe cuándo comienza se sabe cuándo
termina y se va o sea se realiza el
cambio el cambio aquí a una economía de
bajo carbono verdad una economía más
durable un desarrollo durable un
desarrollo
que tiene en cuenta que el planeta no es
infinito y que los recursos son finitos
y que por lo tanto no no estamos siendo
lógicos en la manera de explotar y de
manufacturar y de consumir
entonces desgraciadamente estamos así un
poco con la con la espada en el cuello
de que tenemos que actuar que tenemos
que activar nos porque la transición
esto ya no se llama transición ahora
tenemos que hacerlo en una
transformación y lo digo también porque
no tenemos otra alternativa algunas
personas piensan de que esto va a costar
mucho de que como usted mismo lo dice no
de que es irrealista o
pero sin embargo lo que se tiene se
tiene que decir es contra que comparamos
contra que comparamos para decir que es
realista o no realista para decir que
tenemos tiempo no tenemos tiempo
entonces es unánime en ciencia cuando
uno habla del 95% y más del consenso
científico es porque es una ser una
sorpresa una certeza
entonces ya no podemos esperar más si
tenemos que actuar y tenemos que ir por
el camino de una transformación ya no de
una transición porque el tiempo ha
pasado y algunos y de todas maneras es
un tren que está pasando y que está
causando mucha transformación en la
industria de la manufactura en otras
partes del país
en otros países en otras partes del
planeta y entonces si nosotros queremos
que nuestra economía canadiense siga
siendo competitiva pues no tenemos
alternativa que
alcanzar este tren que ya está pasando
porque si no nos vamos a quedar
alargados en una economía que es del
pasado que una economía que es
contaminante que es una economía basada
en servicios y en bien productos que
tienen un alto precio de carbono y que y
que no van a estar entonces este
buscados por por las nuevas por los
nuevos mercados ahora se adora para
llevar adelante esa transformación
precisamente una de las cosas que hay
que cambiar es el aparato industrial y
económico de algunas provincias que
todavía en el día de hoy dependen
mayoritariamente de la explotación de
recursos naturales pensamos por ejemplo
en el petróleo en alberta como se hace
en el contexto actual de crisis
económica ligada al tema de la pandemia
para que esas provincias puedan contar
con las herramientas necesarias para
producir ese cambio que es profundo que
es largo y que es complicado llevar a
cabo
de nuevo es importante ir y retornar a
lo que decía antes de que cada provincia
es diferente verdad entonces
la minería que sea del petróleo de los
metales va a seguir siendo una necesidad
la cuestión con el petróleo que
justamente lo hablé en otra entrevista
de radio canadá a motor de recherche es
que
es que hay otros tipos de petróleo que
entran en competición con nosotros para
que nuestro petróleo pueda ser vendido
tiene que haber una cuestión de ser
práctico y fácil extracción tiene que
ser fácilmente
accesible a los mercados tiene que ser
accesible al refinado y tiene que
venderse a un precio que permite hacer y
dar beneficios verdad entonces cuando
vemos la situación de las arenas
bituminosas pues tenemos varios
problemas entonces no es solamente el
problema ambiental de las emisiones no
es un problema geopolítico
que incluye que incluye que por ejemplo
el mercado potencial de que es la china
o la india ellas están las 22 países
están haciendo una aceleración increíble
en la utilización de energías renovables
entonces tenemos tenemos muchos
obstáculos que vencer antes de vender de
seguir vendiendo nuestro petróleo de las
arenas bituminosas sin embargo si
tenemos creatividad y si tenemos
innovación entonces eso nos permitiría
por ejemplo de utilizar esta materia que
es muy importante pero que tiene que ser
utilizada con mucha sabiduría
en otros tipos de materiales por ejemplo
la fibra de carbón
por ejemplo ciertos plásticos que son
necesarios en muchas industrias pero son
de plásticos duros refinados etcétera o
por ejemplo también hacer más el
refinado en en canadá y no
necesariamente enviar nuestro producto
bruto hasta el sur de los eeuu para que
ahí se ahí ayala el boom económico y que
ahí es donde se vende el petróleo
entonces tenemos qué
repensar y claro eso eso retorna de
nuevo a la política provincial y
históricamente se sabe que en albert hay
una una lucha de dinastías políticas
siempre conservadora cuando uno compara
la política de lockheed con la política
de ralph klein uno se da cuenta de que a
pesar que los dos eran conservadores
tenían visiones muy muy diferentes en
mientras que uno el primero se veía o
veía un desarrollo completo global
vertical y horizontal de la industria de
petróleo para sacar más más beneficio de
cada barril
el otro no el otro se ha contentado con
solamente en la extracción y la
exportación entonces el petróleo es un
problema cuando se combustión pero no
cuando se hace la captura de carbono en
el carbón en en los materiales
con respecto por ejemplo la minería
también sabemos que hay ahora una
búsqueda de los minerales
elementos raros para justamente las
baterías de los vehículos entonces vamos
a seguir con eso lo que tenemos que
hacer es que la minería mismo si no es
una actividad durable por qué porque el
mismo hecho de extraer elementos no
renovables hace que no es durable pero
lo que tenemos que hacer es tratar de
insertarla en una economía circular en
donde obtenemos va más beneficio por la
por lo que por lo que extraemos verdad
porque en este momento en general en
general
estamos diciendo de que por cada
tonelada que extraemos el 60 por ciento
va a encontrarse como residuo como como
desecho entonces es completamente
ineficaz entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es primeramente la mejor energía
es aquella que no la utilizamos segunda
mente tenemos
segundo tenemos que hacer mucho de la
eficacidad energética y después tenemos
que valorizar los revestidos y en serín
cerrar en insertarlos de nuevo en la
economía circular para que todos estos
residuos se encuentren una una nueva una
nueva función en la sociedad
por último senadora usted nombró a eeuu
y en poco tiempo más este socio de
canadá uno de los principales socios
comerciales sino el principal socio
comercial va a vivir un cambio político
importante la nueva administración la
administración electa ya ha dado señales
de que va a cambiar el rumbo totalmente
en materia de medio ambiente se habla de
que el presidente electo joe biden tiene
la intención de reintegrar eeuu al
actual pacto de parís este cambio
político que va a vivir eeuu en enero
de qué manera favorece si es que lo hace
objetivo que se impone ahora a canadá en
materia climática
a ver mire entonces hay dos maneras de
ver el problema de los gases de
invernadero podemos verlo en función de
las emisiones de cada país y cuando uno
dice eso entonces dice el canadá
contribuye con muy poquito poquitito a
estas emisiones de gas de invernadero
mientras que la china india eeuu son
grandes motores y entonces contribuyen
bastante eso es una manera de verlo pero
cuando lo medimos por persona cuando
medimos por persona cuánto gas de efecto
de invernadero es producido por persona
entonces ahí vemos que los grandes
productores somos todos los habitantes
de los países del g20 verdad mientras
más la calidad alta de la vida
con tendemos a más a consumir imagínense
que esta cuestión del cobismo ha
cambiado tanto los estamos con seguimos
consumiendo los recursos y los servicios
y las manufacturas los productos de base
pero sin embargo no ha no ha habido un
impacto tan dramático en las emisiones
entonces esta oportunidad de que se
presenta de que presidente by the mba
a incluir de nuevo los eeuu va a tener
yo espero un efecto positivo que se
combina justamente con la cuestión de la
de la pandemia que es muy importante por
eso que tratamos de hablar más y más de
una de una recuperación verde solidaria
limpia que podría ser y de las cuales
hemos escrito un libro recientemente que
me gustaría que sí podría publicar y
publicitar sería muy muy bueno en donde
explicamos explicamos esta situación de
que la nueva economía tiene que ser una
economía que que
genere empleos durables limpios que
genere una salud de una bienestar una
prosperidad durable y que a la vez tenga
en consideración los límites del planeta
porque como dije anteriormente vivimos
en un planeta de recursos finitos pero
vivimos con un modelo económico de
crecimiento
infinito y eso no es lógico entonces
estamos con mucha expectativa de ver
cuál es lo que resulta pero pienso que
va a ser positivo señora rosa gálvez
muchas gracias por tu entrevista con
rollo que nos da internacional gracias a
usted